P youtubers is Charlie we got a whole
bunch of new flash stuff we got to talk
about the key to defeating Savitt are in
a new character and we got more teases
for the finale so we got data on the
next couple of blasts episodes and we
learned about the future scientist
that's going to be coming on in helping
them she sounds like she might even be a
season 4 character because they're
introducing her so late in the season
she's sort of like a new version of Tina
McGee but that's not who she is so if
you're new to the channel there's a new
round of the flash ring giveaway going
on all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so we'll start with the scientist then
I'll talk about the next couple of
episodes because they have synopsis so
it talks a little bit about what's going
on with killer frost and we have this
picture to talk about here this crazy
picture of sabotage costume hanging up
in Chains he might be in there he might
not be in there so this almost looks
like the post-apocalyptic version of
STAR Labs so we'll start with the
scientist because she's the key to
defeating Savitt are in a really
interesting way the more traditional way
and then we have the rest of team flash
so right now if you didn't know who this
is
she's and Dudek she was on how she's
been on a bunch of other series you may
remember her from somewhere but her
character's name is Tracy brand and
they're describing her as a smorgasbord
of quirky idiosyncrasies
so she sounds like a new version of Tina
McGee with parody for Harrison wells
someone who's a crazy genius and super
eccentric so what it seems like it's
happening is because killer frost is
taking off like she's gone full-blown
killer frost so she's evil now she's not
technically working with the team but
they've already teased a little bit
about her story arc they'll explain in a
second she's not gone forever it just
you know killer frost from the future
newspaper says that she's still at large
so she's not hanging out in STAR Labs
the whole time so it sounds like this
new female scientist character is going
to fill that whole day to day and it
sounds like most of her scenes are going
to be happening during the present
because in the synopsis they released
for episode 21 it says Barry takes
drastic measures to stops avatar
meanwhile HR continues to push Tracy
brand to design the trap force avatar
and killer frost returns with an
interesting proposal so that sort of
jumps over episode 20 stuff because
that's also killer frost centric you get
the vibe versus killer frost
sisqó vibed in the future way back
during Episode six so as we get closer
to the finale things were getting
crazier and crazier in there changing
less and less about what's happening in
the future
Catelyn became killer frost Cisco ended
up fighting her so it's almost like
they're running towards the future that
they're trying to avoid which is a very
tropi thing big trap in the future you
try to change time to avoid it by the
reverse flashes explanation time will
find a way to replace that terrible
thing with something that's just as bad
so with killer frost taking off the
female scientist sort of fills that void
that Caitlin would normally fill on STAR
Labs but she's a biologist this
scientist is more of like a female
version of Harrison wells from earth-2
in Tina McGee with sort of a lighter
energy to her they call her super
eccentric and quirky I don't think that
means she's going to be super fun and
happy all the time but it does make her
sound like she's not going to be a super
big like Harrison wells from
earth-2 is going to be but she'll
balance out a chart because he's been
super silly and if there is any
character that I want to see go away it
would be HR like you start to like him
more and more but you can kind of see
how too much of his character just kind
of grates on you you need somebody to
balance that out so the Tracy Brand
character is not somebody from the
comics the name brand sounds like Boston
brand which is dead man but I don't
think that she has any connection to him
so the name is either fake and it's like
the Jay Garrick hunter zolomon twist
where you find out their real name later
on and she winds up being a big comic
book character there were a couple new
characters introduced during the flash
rebirth there's a Mina character there's
a Speed Force scientist that's working
at STAR Labs so they're always
introducing new characters from the
comics she could wind up being one of
those people but I'm not expecting it
the TV show introduces people like
Harrison wells he's original to the TV
show even though it gives in a very
comic book II origin story like you Bart
dawn in season one and then sort of
taking it in a different direction
season 2 season 3 so I like the actress
hopefully she'll come back for season 4
because it sounds like unless they
completely reverse everything think
Caitlin will continue to be a version of
killer frost even if she's able to work
with the team because it says in episode
21 she has an interesting proposal for
the team
one week after she's full-blown fighting
vibe in episode 20 so it sounds like
she's going to go crazy for a little
while but then she'll get it under
control and she'll find a way to work
with the team even if she's never going
to completely be our version of Kaitlyn
again and then they post pictures like
this like the people were like okay
we're done filming the flash thank you
so much for a wonderful season and
you're like wait a minute
this is a version of Harrison wells it
could be HR it could be earth - Harrison
wells in Kaitlyn looking like Kaitlyn
what does that mean clearly there's a
funeral so they're definitely messing
with our heads
and they also posted this picture from
the finale to like the very final scene
that they film so they don't always film
chronologically but I know you're
looking at this photo here and you're
like hey wait a minute who's in this
photo who's missing so you have Tom
Cavanagh with the crew the people that
actually film the episodes and work on
them and then you have iris West
standing here so what it sounds like is
if this is the very last moment of
season three then it's going to be an
iris Westbury scene where she's thinking
about him being gone so it definitely
lends credence to the idea that Barry's
going to get stuck in the Speed Force to
pay for his crimes and then season four
will start with the rest of team flash
trying to find a way to bring him back
so that's just one option the second
option is this is happening at some
other point in the episode and they're
just filming it out of order but I do
like the idea that Barry does have to
pay for his crimes
so whoever ends up dying in addition to
that Barry has to go away for a little
while and do some time before he comes
back
but don't worry people freak out about
Barry Allen leaving the flash does that
mean the Kid Flash is going to be the
main version of the flash
they might tease that very briefly in
episode 1 but remember what happened
during flashpoint the very first episode
like Barry should have lost his powers
the way he lost them during Comic Book
flashpoint but they didn't even take it
that far so you can see a situation
where by you know Grant Gustin gets a
lot of questions say hey is barry coming
back is he going to be stuck in the
Speed Force and he has to pretend like
he doesn't know what's going to happen
maybe Barry won't come back but
everybody who's ever read a single comic
book or watches TV at all and follows
the plot knows that there is always
going to be a very Alan on the flash
so it's one of those funny situations
whereby actors have to live for the
studio because they're under contract
like you can't give away spoilers
even though fans know 99% what's going
to happen and who's coming back but
defeating savat are so you may have seen
some pictures from the set that lend
credence to the idea of Tracy brand's
character creating a trap force avatar
that might be what this scene is from
here after they're able to trap him but
this is what the suit looks like just in
the light of day with no CG or anything
like that I know it looks better when
it's all glowy but the interesting thing
here is when they started to analyze
pieces of the suit they said that it was
basically frictionless it had technology
that they didn't have access to so it's
almost like savitur got it from the
future and who's travelling to the
future is Barry now I don't want to say
that Barry is avatar I'm not jumping on
that train right away but there is a lot
of evidence that's stacking against that
so there are a couple big Savatage
theories right now let me know which one
you like the most in the comments below
does there a couple of things that we
know are probably going to be happening
at the end of the season one somebody is
going to end up dying into Barry is
going to have to pay the price for his
crimes temporarily until team flash gets
him back so what I'm going to do next is
is they aired a bunch of black panther
footage I'll do a breakdown of that that
should post in the next couple hours so
three videos today while you wait for
that you can click here for my Rick and
Morty VR episode one they recorded a
whole bunch of new materials a lot of
fun and you can click here for that
arrow finale trailer thank you so much
for watching let's high-five I'll see
you guys in the next video